(audience clapping)
Hi, how are you?
Good, how are you doin'?
Good.
The last time I saw you,
I was like attacking you at an event.
I was like "I love you! I love you so much."
(audience laughing)
No, I think it was me.
I think I was attacking you.
So I feel like,
I like, full on like accosted you,
but, so thanks for having me on the show.
It's nice to see you.
You know, we're getting Katelyn ready
for her prom today and I was just so curious.
Do you remember your prom?
Of course.
So I went to two proms, - [Drew] Oh.
well I actually went to three, but I went to two
Oh.
I know.
Oh, that's Jim Daly.
He's gonna kill me.
So that's Jim Daly.
He was my,
I was in Camelot in my, when I was a junior
and he was Lancelot.
Ah.
And I was Guinevere.
And so I asked him, he was a year younger than me.
So I asked him to prom and I drove
and then I tried to make out with him,
but he wasn't very much interested.
And then this is Chris pinching my skirt.
And you'll see that my knees bent
because I was a little bit taller than him
and I was super nervous,
but he was like my first boyfriend.
And he was so sweet and he took me to his senior prom.
Ah.
Oh, he was like my first like boyfriend.
So that was the best prom.
Cause he actually kissed me.
I love the stories in these pictures.
But wait, did you ever like
didn't you get a perm at one point?
I remember hearing , cause I got a permit one point.
Oh yeah, because my hair is like, naturally straight.
Oh yeah, there we go.
There's so many things unfortunate about this photo.
The clubbings, the clear braces that aren't really clear
and the bad perm.
You were performing when you had this perm.
In fact, I think we have a clip of you
which is something we love to do on this show.
Let's roll it.
Oh god.
You can't do it big with your Mouth.
(audience laughing)
I can explain
By the way, I wasn't bucking at the perm,
I was more bucking or freaking out
about the message cause that is like
in-your-face intense.
But I love the like,
you're going to die to the Jazz-e song.
Like they're like dead, dead, dead today
Death.
Yeah.
(people laughing)
And I think,
I'm pretty sure in that commercial is my Caboodle,
remember, the caboodle?
And they're back.
I know.
I already that one for my daughter, it's purple.
So anyway,
that was a PSA for obvious for smoking.
Anti-smoking ad.
It was "Smoking Stinks".
And so I was hired.
That was like my local claim to fame.
I remember I was like,
I finally made it
when the drive-through guy at taco bell was like
"Are you the girl on the Smoking Stinks commercial?"
Yeah, like, Uh-huh.
I am.
I'm like, yeah.
Now, you we're crocheting.
Right?
And you're a big crochet-er.
Yes. I started crocheting when I was 19.
So I've been doing it for 25, 20 plus years.
It's something that I love to do.
It started off, like I had lost my voice.
I had laryngitis and started crocheting
just to give myself something to do.
Wow.
Oh, there's my daughter.
No, your stuff is amazing.
For me it's like an emotional thing.
Oh yeah, there's a sweater for her.
I've made things that have gotten me through breakups
or deaths or even like the birth of my daughter.
Like as I was waiting for her to be born,
I was like "I don't know what to do,
I feel powerless so I'm gonna make her a blanket."
So you can like pour your energy into something
and then it exists forever.
And it's this heirloom that could be passed on.
And a lot of the things that I've made
are like little time capsules.
I have to tell you too, your crochet is not normal Sutton.
You could open up the dopest store and charge a bundle.
Your work is extraordinary.
Thank you.
Would you ever consider selling them?
It is like my dream.
I mean, it's so funny.
I'm like I'm an actress, singer, dancer, crocheter.
I think I would be so happy
like just running my own Etsy store and just making things.
I feel like the people that really know me,
know me as like the, the crazy crafter.
I'm really glad to uncover these personal layers
and celebrate your final season.
"Younger" has been such a beloved show.
How does it feel to say goodbye to this very long chapter?
It feels very bittersweet.
It was seven years of my life
but I just feel like I hit the jackpot.
Amazing cast crew,
just in a wonderful place to work, a wonderful place to be.
And it lasted,
that energy lasted for seven years.
And, but& that final day when they say
and that's a series wrap on "Younger".
You know,
it felt very finite and I realized,
"Oh I won't be with all of these people."
You know, this combination of people
probably will never be together in this way again.
Yeah.
And that makes me sad
but I feel so incredibly grateful.
And I really,
it was like the job of a lifetime.
Well, be sure, please everybody to check out
her concert as well as the final season of Younger
which airs on Paramount Plus and Hulu.
It has been so fun, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me and that's for just being you.
Cause I really admire you so much.
(upbeat music)